hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing Voldemort
Dumbledore and one rather large question
that I'm sure has crossed the minds of
every Harry Potter fan at one point or
another why didn't Dumbledore just hunt
Voldemort down I know I know it's not
that simple logistically the subject is
precarious to say the least but just for
a moment let's pretend that Dumbledore
decided to set off in search of
Voldemort and simply killed the
tyrannical dark wizard effectively
stopping him in his tracks and if not
kill him couldn't he have imprisoned him
in the same way that he imprisoned
Grindelwald in the event of either of
these situations what would have
happened next would this have been any
kind of a permanent solution and of
course the big one is this situation
even a feasible one join me as we unpack
the question of why on Earth Dumbledore
failed to defeat Voldemort all by
himself instead relying on the fabled
boy who lived let's dive in the first
thing that I want to reinforce is that
Dumbledore was unquestionably one of the
most powerful Wizards in the Harry
Potter Universe from an extremely young
age Dumbledore's magical abilities
consistently turned heads particularly
his skills surrounding charms and
Transfiguration he also did
exceptionally well on his newts and
Griselda marchbanks a professor working
for the Wizarding examinations Authority
remarked that Albus was able to do
things with the wand that she had never
seen before in his youth Dumbledore also
spent much of his time with garlic
Grindelwald another one of the Wizarding
world's most powerful Wizards by
association it's likely that the two
boys skill sets merged to some extent
resulting in each wizard achieving a
greater level of power than what would
have been independently possible as
Dumbledore Grew Older he left no stone
unturned when it came to magical
abilities becoming a master of
transfiguration charms potions Elemental
Magic occlimency and more Dumbledore is
truly the exception to the phrase jack
of all trades master of none as he was a
master of all so if Dumbledore was so
powerful what was stopping him from
tracking Voldemort down and overpowering
him putting an end to the Dark Lord's
Reign well there are a number of reasons
the first reason is that Dumbledore
though exceedingly powerful was equally
as modest this is exemplified in the
following conversation between him and
McGonagall but you're different everyone
knows you're the only one you know oh
all right Voldemort was frightened of
you flatter me said Dumbledore calmly
Voldemort had powers I will never have
to which McGonagall replies only because
you're too well Noble to use them though
Dumbledore possessed power that was
potentially unmatched by every other
wizard he believed that Voldemort had
achieved a level of power akin to his
own with the belief that Voldemort was
just as strong if not stronger than him
why would the wise tactician that is
Dumbledore embark on such a risky
mission
furthermore Dumbledore knew all about
Voldemort's horcrux's horrific dark
relics that tied Voldemort to the Mortal
realm so long as Voldemort possessed all
of his horcruxes Voldemort would be able
to return back to the land of the living
over and over Dumbledore on the other
hand did not have this luxury while
Dumbledore was incredibly powerful he
was also very much Mortal as shown
during the events Atop The astronomy
Tower in the Half-Blood Prince even if
Dumbledore was entirely confident that
he was 10 20 even 30 stronger than
Voldemort there was still a chance that
he could be defeated by Voldemort and if
he lost then it would be game over sure
with the knowledge of Voldemort's
horcrux's Dumbledore may have just tried
to overpower and imprison Voldemort but
I imagine that task would have been even
more difficult even with an existing
power Gap Voldemort would not have been
easily subdued with power and power
alone this brings me to my next Point
instead of actively pursuing Voldemort
Dumbledore instead made it his mission
to look after to others and ensure that
those under his care were well protected
Dumbledore recognized the importance of
preserving The Wizarding world's
cultural heritage and he took his role
as Headmaster of Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry very seriously
and said Master he was responsible for
preserving the school's traditions and
ensuring that future generations of
wizards would be able to learn and grow
in a safe and supportive environment had
Dumbledore gone off on some Dangerous
Mission and Fallen at the hands of
Voldemort The Wizarding World would have
been that much more open to attacks
Voldemort was a powerful and ruthless
wizard that feared no one except for
Dumbledore as long as Dumbledore was
around Voldemort would be forced to lurk
in the shadows at least somewhat and
slowly rebelled without Dumbledore
Voldemort would have been able to launch
an attack on The Wizarding World much
sooner there are several instances in
the series where Voldemort expresses
fear or concern about Dumbledore for
example in Harry Potter and the
Half-Blood Prince Voldemort is shown to
be worried about the fact that
Dumbledore has been studying him and
gathering information about his past
Voldemort is also known to have avoided
direct confrontation with Dumbledore
whenever possible overall while
Voldemort was a powerful and
intimidating wizard he did fear
Dumbledore's strength and intelligence
and recognized him as a formidable
opponent regardless of how Voldemort
sought to portray himself a Fearless
bloodthirsty warlord most witches and
wizards knew that deep down he feared
Dumbledore and Voldemort knew that
Dumbledore had more than enough talent
to defeat him in order to protect his
students and preserve other aspects of
The Wizarding World Dumbledore decided
not to try and hunt down Voldemort
himself instead he focused his efforts
on teaching protecting and empowering
others the next reason that Dumbledore
avoided confronting Voldemort was the
fabled prophecy which foretold the birth
of a child with the power to Vanquish
Voldemort the one with the power to
Vanquish the dark lord approaches born
to those who have Thrice to find him
born as the seventh month die
and the Dark Lord will Mark him as his
equal but he will have power the Dark
Lord knows not and either must die at
the hand of the other for neither can
live while the other survives the
prophecy essentially predicted that
Harry Potter and Lord Voldemort were
destined to face each other in a final
confrontation with one ultimately
defeating the other Dumbledore believed
that this prophecy referred to Young
Harry that it was Harry's Destiny to
defeat Voldemort and not his own for
this reason he chose to support Harry
and give him Aid where possible rather
than face Voldemort himself what good
could come from facing Voldemort if he
wasn't the one destined to defeat him
the final reason that Dumbledore may
have avoided hunting Voldemort comes
down to his character for most of his
youth Dumbledore was a man of dubious
morality often making the wrong choices
in the pursuit of power however
following the death of his sister and
his parting of ways from Grindelwald
Dumbledore no longer glorified power in
the way that he once did the immense
trauma that he had endured heard for
stumbledore to sit down and re-evaluate
what was important to him in this period
of reevaluation he realized that it was
no longer his ambition to seek power or
assert dominance over others hunting
down Voldemort and having the dark lord
grovel at his feet for Freedom would
have been against the new way of life
that he had paved for himself
Dumbledore's sheer desire to avoid any
form of power is well demonstrated in
the following passage years passed there
were rumors about him they said he had
procured a wand of immense power I
meanwhile was offered the post of
minister of magic not once but several
times naturally I refused I had learned
that I was not to be trusted with power
but you'd have been better much better
than fudge or scrimja burst out Harry
would I are stumbledore heavily I'm not
so sure I had proven as a very young man
that power was my weakness and my
Temptation it is a Curious Thing Harry
but perhaps those who are best suited to
power are those who have never sought it
those who like you you have leadership
thrust upon them and take up the mantle
because they must and find their own
surprise they wear it well I was safer
at Hogwarts I think I was a good teacher
and that's it for this video what do you
think did this thought ever occur to you
leave a comment down below and if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember there is plenty to be
learned even from a bad teacher what not
to do how not to be